we are learning more about the suspect
in the kidnapping of the Jamie Claus and
the killing of her parents Jake
Patterson is his name he was moved
yesterday from Wisconsin's Barron County
Jail to the jail in Polk County that's
about 30 miles away the 21 year old man
is being held on five million dollars
bail
Jamie yuccas is at a church in Barron
County Wisconsin where a prayer service
will be held this weekend Jamie good
morning to you good morning as new
information comes in we've noticed the
mood in this community shift from joy to
shock over the horrific details of Jamie
Casas kidnapping and the murder of both
her parents now we are learning more
about the suspects last job before his
alleged crimes Jake Patterson only
worked at saputo cheese factory for two
days but according to a criminal
complaint it was on his drive to work on
one of those days that he spotted Jamie
Claus
getting on a school bus and decided he
was going to kidnap her the company told
CBS News they fired Patterson when he
failed to show up for his third day of
work according to the complaint
Patterson was plotting Jamie's abduction
while still at the job he bought a face
mask at a Walmart on his last day the
same mask he allegedly wore during the
October crimes on Tuesday Patterson was
moved to the Polk County Jail because
Jamie Casas cousin Lindsey Smith works
at the Barron County Jail Smith spoke
about Patterson with Gayle King earlier
this week have you seen him I have not I
will not deal with him I can't I think
it's fair on my end and his that we do
not see each other
the Marine Corps confirms that in 2015
Patterson was prematurely discharged
from service after about a month in a
statement to CBS News a spokesperson
said it was indicative of the fact that
the character of his service was
incongruent with marine corps
expectations and standards while
investigators work to determine
Patterson's motive for the October
crimes the close-knit community that
helped raise Jamie is beginning to heal
Patti Gerber taught Jamie's religious
education class
she believes faith will help Jamie move
forward faith know that she's loved by
God she's loved by others she's perfect
the way she is
I think that will help her a special
prayer service for Jamie will be held
here on Sunday the prayer service is to
also thank the community for all of its
support a larger celebration though is
being planned for later this month Nora
right Jamie and thank you for all your
great reporting on this story